good morning hick it's Tuesday so before
Sarah and I were married and before we
were dating we were friends and one
evening in like 2003 we were hanging out
at her apartment and she showed me some
of her recent paintings they were mostly
paintings of lines and they made me
think about how it's actually impossible
to draw a straight line because both the
hand and the paint are imprecise and
unpredictable anyway I liked them a lot
and so I asked her if I could buy a
painting and she gave me a painting this
painting for the friends and family
discounted price of fifty dollars so I
went home got the painting framed and
put it up in my apartment oh God uh oh
uh I'm sorry I feel an advertisement
coming on now people are going to say
John you're 45 don't take this risk but
I'm gonna take it did you know that the
awesome socks Club
taking subscribers again my brother's
wild idea of Reinventing the sock
business by allowing people to have
amazing socks and donating 100 of the
proceeds to charity has exploded we've
got ankle socks we've got regular socks
Link in the doobly-doo use my affiliate
link not Hanks because he's already had
a lot of sales all right thanks to
awesomesocs.club for sponsoring today's
video is what I would say if this had
actually been a paid advertisement right
so I get the painting frame and I put it
up in my apartment here's what it looked
like I loved looking at this painting
kind of reminded me of the paths
raindrops traces they slide down a
window and I just loved how the lines
got denser closer to the middle and how
they even sometimes converged now
observant viewers will have already
identified the issue but I certainly
didn't I just liked the painting in fact
we're gonna know I still love it I'm
reminded of the veins of a ginkgo leaf
how they approach each other without
ever becoming each other anyway a few
months after I hung up the painting
Sarah came over to my apartment and let
me know in the politest way possible
that I had hung it upside down in fact
it was supposed to look like this which
now that I look at it is probably better
like this way it reminds me of the great
Flannery O'Connor title everything that
rises must converge in the years since
we hung the painting at multiple
orientations like recently it's been in
my office sideways so the lines now seem
to me like distant mountain ranges or
rows of crops and far off Fields I've
been thinking about this partly because
news recently broke that appear at
Montreal painting has been hanging
upside down in a German art museum for
75 years now the story like a lot of
stories turns out to be much more
complicated than its headline the piece
was unfinished Mondrian was probably
working on it when he died and he was
known to work on things upside down or
sideways on his easel and because the
piece is unfinished and unsigned it's
impossible to know how mondrial would
have wanted the painting oriented as the
Museum's director put it we cannot know
what is correct or incorrect which is a
great sentence one that I should utter
more often but I'm also thinking about
the upside down Sarah painting because
it's a reminder to me that art can bring
wonder and pleasure in unexpected ways
and whether the artist intended each
possible road to wonder is not as
important as whether a viewer can find
that Wonder art that is created only for
the person who created it can be great
and valuable but art that is created to
be shared is inherently a collaboration
it is a commingling of the artist's
attention and the viewer's attention the
work of art is the place where those
attentions come together I think for art
to work it has to involve Mutual
generosity the making of the work is a
gift to an audience and in turn the
audience's attention is a gift to the
artist this gift exchange is at the
center of how I understand art and 19
years on I find that this painting
continues to reward my attention no
matter its orientation in new and
thrilling ways to such a degree that at
this point we cannot know what is
correct or incorrect Hank I'll see you
on Friday